oui par la matière il m'avait envoyé
également avec kelly était très content
au départ de portée sauf que non
seulement évidemment elle a hurlé en
plus on attendait surtout elle frappait
tous les zombies qui venait ce qui ne se
fait pas quand même s'ils sont des
acteurs à tous frappé tout le truc en
rampant en tenant les piannencs bernard
c'était vraiment serré
quel est le truc que vous n'ayez jamais
osé faire à l'antenne castaldi tient à
ce que j'ai jamais osé faire j'en ai
fait beaucoup d avantages
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas fait à l'inter il
dit cautionner un avortement forcé dans
ces crétins excusez moi est ce que je
pense là vous pensez à ça non c'est vrai
que on a refusé ont été quelques-uns il
y avait un des candidats sur ces cas
story qui était était enceinte
mais la question s'est posée de lui
faire prendre une pilule abortive
et là on était obligé d'expliquer à
l'époque à la direction de la chaîne que
c'était extrêmement traumatisant qui
savait des conséquences que ça y avait
un moment il fallait quand même expulsé
l'embryon est dit on ne peut pas
cautionner ça on peut pas le filmer et
le suivre là donc c'est qu'ils ont la
jeunesse si vous faites ça ce sera sans
moi ils vont aller le film ah oui ou non
c'est à dire oui à la fabrique à ce
stade il ait dit trépidante abeba il me
sourit jamais fait ou à l'antenne moi
j'ai jamais osé dire à des invités qui
dont visiblement il n'avait pas du tout
envie d'être là bas c'est à voir si t'as
pas envie est la casse toi ça démange me
servez vous devriez